-Hello!
-Thank you, and welcome.
Look at you.
You always have something.
I want to thank you again
for being here,
'cause you were
here back in April.
-Yeah.
-And so much has changed
since then.
Obviously, you're now back
filming season three of "Pose."
-Yes.
-How is it going?
-It's wild.
It's crazy.
I'm excited to be back.
We're all glad to be back.
Disney, who now owns FX, has put
brilliant protocols in place.
Everybody looks like
a stormtrooper.
-[ Laughs ]
-I feel so sorry for the crew,
because they have to have
goggles and masks and shields.
-They have that here, too,
I agree.
-But that allows for us
to be able to go to work.
This is a wild, crazy time.
And I'm just grateful that there
are people
who care enough
to take the right steps,
to believe science
and get us back to work.
-You were nominated
for another Emmy this year.
And even though it was virtual,
you still showed up and
delivered with awesome style.
Look at that, come on, now.
-Ah!
-Come on, now.
-Yes.
-What is the piano?
-Okay, so, I'm working
with a new stylist,
Ty Hunter of Beyoncé fame.
And he and his assistant Colin
showed up on Emmy day
with a piano that they had found
the night before on Craigslist
and spray-painted white.
-I love it.
-And they brought a backdrop
and a photographer,
and they came out
to my front yard,
and we took some photos,
darling.
-I love that you did that.
You know, I don't know
if anyone else did that
for, like, a virtual event.
So that was pretty cool
that you did that.
-It was my first.
It was my first,
because I hadn't been doing
any virtual red carpets
through the entire quarantine.
And I just thought
this will pack a punch,
because
I'm nominated for an Emmy.
It's a big deal.
And I haven't been doing them.
-Yeah.
And I bet you everyone
has been calling
and asking, "Will Billy show up?
And will Billy
do something for us?
Will he get the hat?
Will he do something?"
And you go, "Yeah, just chill.
I'll take care of business."
-Yeah.
I wasn't doing it
because the moment that we're in
didn't make me feel like
doing anything like that.
-Yeah. I agree.
-You know, and so I
just wanted to be respectful.
-Yeah.
-And I think, you know,
having six months
of not doing that, you know,
and then embracing it
for the moment,
which was the Emmys,
was a good thing.
-And it made people happy.
-Yes.
-And you see the things
that we miss, and you go,
"Aw, I miss that."
-Yes.
-Sadly, you know,
Broadway announced
that it will be shut down
through June,
which is just awful.
You think about this.
You've been doing a lot
to celebrate Broadway,
as we wait for it to come back.
One of your early Broadway roles
was Teen Angel in "Grease,"
and you posted a photo
of your first time
on "The Tonight Show."
Here it is.
-[ Laughs ]
-What do you remember
about this?
-I remember that we were on tour
with the pre-Broadway production
of "Grease,"
that starred Rosie O'Donnell
and Megan Mullally.
-Megan Mullally?
-Pre-"Will & Grace."
-I did not know that.
-And we were in Costa Mesa,
and "The Tonight Show"
was going to have us,
and they came to the show,
and they saw the whole show.
And they chose my number.
And so I ended up
being able to go on.
And then it was a surprise,
because after the number,
Jay Leno paneled me,
which was a big deal.
Because, like, I wasn't supposed
to go and talk.
I was just supposed to be
a musical guest and sing.
-And you scored.
-Yes.
-There's this trend online
right now, I just recently did,
where people share photos
and they go how it started,
and how it's going.
And people are doing it.
You've been having fun with it.
You made one
just for us tonight.
-Yes.
-Let's take a look at this.
Now, that is how it started,
which I have questions about.
-[ Laughs ]
-I see how it's going.
Let's start with how it's going.
Where was that?
Was that "Kinky Boots"?
-That was "Kinky Boots," 2013,
the Tony Awards.
-Oh, come on.
-So that was the original dream
come true.
The dream that I started having
when you see me
on the left over there.
-Now, what was happening when
you're on the left over there?
How old are you?
-Okay, so, I am 13 years old.
I was at Reizenstein
Middle School.
I had discovered musical theater
in the sixth grade.
I was in the eighth grade.
And I figured,
here I've spent the last
two years playing second banana.
So I'm going to be
the star of the show.
The show was announced.
It's "Oliver."
I went to the library.
I took out the cast album.
I learned "Where Is Love?"
I came, I sang,
I did my audition.
The cast list goes up,
and it says Oliver Twist --
Eric Pearson.
Well, I storm
into the director's office.
Mr. Ken Lutz,
who was the instrumental
teacher,
who I'm still friends
with to this day.
And I was like, "How dare you?"
You know, like,
I went off on him.
And he said, "Billy, Billy,
Billy, you, Fagin."
If anybody knows "Oliver Twist,"
I was cast as Fagin.
Fagin is really the star
of the show.
Fagin is really the lead.
And I was like, "Okay."
He said, "Well, take the script
home and read it."
Well, of course, at 13,
you're just counting your lines.
And Fagin, I was just
counting my lines.
And Fagin doesn't even enter
until the last scene
of the first act.
I was like, "How are you
going to tell me
I'm the lead of a show
named 'Oliver'
and I'm not playing Oliver?"
-[ Laughs ]
-But that is when I discovered
the power
of a star entrance, darling.
Because the children
were waiting for me!
I didn't realize it was that.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
-I didn't understand that.
-Oh, my gosh.
This is ridiculous.
-The children were
waiting for me.
At 13, I arrived on the stage
to applause, darling.
-The children were
waiting for you.
Oh, my gosh.
I don't think
there's anything more --
you get that special feeling
when a kid is doing "Oliver,"
and they sing
"Where Is Love?"
Just, like, the voice,
and it's just so little.
-Yeah, but for me,
I'm reviewing the situation,
an octave up
in a Pittsburgh/cockney accent.
There is video.
I don't know where it is.
But I'm sure
somebody will post it now
when they see this.
-Next time you come on,
we got to play that.
-It's out there somewhere.
[ Laughs ]
-Billy, you've also been using
your platform
to encourage people to vote.
-Yes.
-Like your beautiful
blazer says.
And be active.
I know last time you were on,
we talked about your version of
"For What It's Worth."
-Yes.
-Man, oh, man, did it explode.
Everyone loved it.
It ended up being on
Obama's summer playlist.
-Yes.
-Did you freak out?
You go, "Wait. Wow."
-It's just -- It's astonishing.
I've been an independent artist
for a long time.
I had a R&B record deal
back in the late '90s,
and they dismissed me.
So I've been on my own.
I've been doing
independent music for a while.
So to have this happen,
to be able to crack through
in this way for something
that I just remained persistent
and consistent on
is really, really amazing.
It's really powerful, and, it's
made it to the list of,
like, being in contention
for a Grammy.
-[ Clapping ]
This is what I'm talking about.
See, that's what you do.
-So I am like just keep going.
If there's anything that
I can say to folks,
just keep going, just keep
showing up for your life
and putting one foot
in front of the other.
-It was great.
I love that you did it.
And I was so happy
to see it on that list.
I go, "Oh, he's got to be, like,
just freaking out right now."
-Yeah, it's amazing.
It's amazing.
-You narrate a new docuseries
called "Equal,"
which is on HBO Max,
which, by the way,
is killing it right now.
-Yeah.
-Could you set it up
for everybody?
-Yeah, you know,
I think we as a society
know a lot about
LGBTQ+ history
from 1969, which is
the Stonewall uprising, forward.
What "Equal" does is it
really talks
about what came before that.
You know, the history
that came before 1969.
So probably around the turn
of the century, even as far back
as like the late 1800s,
up into the Stonewall uprising.
And I learned a lot about stuff
that I didn't know.
And they called and asked me
to be the voice.
So that's what I did.
It's really exciting,
and it's really, really good.
Really empowering.
-You are so talented,
you are fun, you are fearless.
We love you here.
I want to show everyone a clip
of "Equal,"
which premieres
Thursday on HBO Max.
Take a look at this.
-100 years ago, lesbians
and gays could find their fun
together
in the underground world.
We're talking
the Roaring Twenties
and the Dirty Thirties.
You know, Prohibition,
speakeasies, and the like.
It was still on the down-low,
but you could find the gay life,
if you knew
where to look for it.
But by the 1950s,
queer love was forbidden love.
A conservative chill set in
across postwar America.
-Billy Porter.
All four episodes of "Equal"
begin streaming
this Thursday on HBO Max.
Next time you come on, Billy,
I need that video.
I'm gonna find it.
I want to hear that.
-We'll find it.
I'm sure I will hear
from some folks.
We got that one, and we got
"Guys and Dolls"
from when I was
in high school, too.
They're out there somewhere.
I've seen them.
-I love that the kids
were waiting for you.
They were waiting for
your entrance.
-The children were waiting
for me, honey.
Gave me applause, darling.